the 19th century saw many countries pop
into existence as nationalist movements
sprang up across the world few had as
much of a lasting impact as the creation
of germany which not only saw the birth
of a new nation but the rise of a great
power and given the power that this new
country held how did other states react
to its creation how did the world's
great powers react to the birth of
germany as you'll likely know germany
came into existence after the north
german confederation and these smaller
german-speaking states won a war against
france in 1870. after the collapse of
the french army german leaders gathered
in versailles and proclaimed the
creation of the german empire with the
north german leader and prussian king as
its emperor as such you'll guess that
the french reaction was one of anger
mostly because of the embarrassing
defeat and occupation thing but also
because this new germany took with it a
part of france in the form of alsace
lorraine that said there was nothing
they could do to oppose it and frankly
they had their own problems in the north
the british position was mixed on the
one hand france had just lost a thing
which would never not be funny on the
other hand sheer panic because there was
now a new threat to british power prime
minister gladstone denounced the
unification and tried to get countries
like sweden norway denmark and belgium
on board shockingly none of these wanted
to upset the new major power sitting
right next to them and so they said
nothing as such britain grumbled but
understood that it was a done deal and
now many in government saw that germany
not france or russia would be the main
threat from now on and for many that
meant war was soon to follow to germany
south the austro-hungarian empire wasn't
too pleased about this development it
had just lost a war to prussia five
years earlier and given the number of
german-speaking people living in the
empire there were fears that they would
be on the receiving end of any future
german expansion as such the viennese
government was quick to accept any
offers of alliance from germany to
protect itself it also turned its
attention to the balkans from then on
recognising that expansion back into
italy or restoring its old german
alliances were both dead ends to the
east russia was largely happy with
german unification russia's main concern
at this point was britain and so a
powerful industrialized state in the
centre of europe was seen as a potential
ally in any future war also given both
were absolutist conservative powers
there was zero chance that they'd ever
come to blows themselves and thus
nothing could go wrong across the
atlantic the united states welcomed the
news president ulysses s grants or
german unification are somewhat
analogous to the birth of the united
states and it was hoped that this new
germany with its male suffrage is
elected parliament in its many
individual states would see the
liberalization of germany but fun fact
no the italians also freshly unified
were pleased with the birth of germany
the war had seen french troops leave the
papal state which allowed for italy to
quickly annex it and it was hoped that a
strong germany would help italy counter
any austrian attempts to return there in
the future and one thing that most
nations had in common when thinking
about german unification was the sheer
surprise at how quickly france had lost
it wasn't just the creation of a new
large economy or cultural center it was
the birth of a massive military power
whose friendship could change the
balance of power in europe forever after
a fact which the new germany was well
aware of i hope you enjoyed this episode
and thank you for watching with a
special thanks to my patrons james
bissonette kelly moneymaker corso wolff
jordan longley adam stalter jerry landon
marcus arsenault wyan hockey spencer
lightfoot words about books podcast
gustav swan captain cydog roddy martin
common yoon boogerly wiggly mrs marvin
cassow aaron the white matthew shipley
alex schwinn maggie patzkowski anthony
beckett maxon flaudio the mcwhopper
corey turner spinning three plates
coppertone winston k wood charles the
first and scottish trekkie